my name is Casey Neistat and I hope that
was interesting right cool cool okay
awesome I'm psyched then there's great
questions by the way really smart I take
this offer leave this on Casey's one
seriously erratic dude I could never
learn enough from a true visionary I
called him up and told him I had a
question to ask do you even like
yourself do I even like myself
[Music]
[Music]
3:30 in the morning January 2 2018 we've
just run up a mountain hangout with
Casey they say dude so I'm just gonna
ask you one simple question a pressing
question a question I've been asking
myself recently do I even like myself
being here now being yourself I think
it's very very hard to do that is
absolutely foundational to liking myself
or you know
loving Who I am as a person I could
issue you sort of [ __ ] platitudes
about deserving this fighting for it and
all that [ __ ] but it would be
[ __ ]
when I was young I felt frustrated
because I didn't know how to express
myself and when I was a teenager and I
first discovered making videos that felt
like the most perfect form of
self-expression if I can't be honest and
authentic on camera and with my audience
then what's the point in doing all of
this because then I'm sharing a
caricature of myself and not who I
honestly am I think the two guiding
principles that I follow in life are
work hard and be brave if you do those
two things you can accomplish anything
if you're willing to work for something
you'll probably get it and if you're
willing to be brave then you're much
more likely to succeed at that something
that you're chasing after when I look in
the mirror I see the luckiest guy on
planet Earth
[Music]
I love my life and I love the fact that
I've been afforded such like incredible
opportunities in this life
[Music]